-Thanksgiving is coming up
What are you gonna do?
-Oh, you know.
Well, here I am.
-You're here.
-I live in Los Angeles.
-Right.
Are you gonna make it back
-Yes, if the weather --
if all things,
if I'm still sitting up
and taking nourishment tomorrow,
I'll be on an airplane
early in the morning
to join my wife Emily
and our two kids.
-Great.
-I have a 4-year-old
and 2-year-old, two boys.
-Very close to us, yeah.
-Very close.
We should have a play date
-Yes, please.
-In fact, my wife is doing
what I think Alexi is doing,
which is lobbying for
another baby.
-Oh, she is lobbying for
another baby?
We're on the fence.
But I can see us doing it,
now more than ever.
[ Laughter ]
-Really? You can?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then, you know,
and I don't know.
And then, once if you do it,
you might end up with a baby
[ Laughter ]
What about you?
Are you feeling -- Are you pro
-Uh, I-I-I sit at her feet
Anything she thinks
is a good idea to me.
-Yeah.
-And she's, you know --
-Do the kids have an input yet
Have you checked it with them?
-Do you want
a little baby sister?
Wouldn't you like
I think they've said yes,
you know, but what do they know?
[ Laughter ]
But I think --
So, you're feeling --
-I certainly don't think -
I came from two,
so I thought,
"Oh, that's perfect."
But at the same time, I'm like
I wouldn't be like,
"We'd regret it."
I don't think we'd ever sa
on a road trip, you know,
"This could have been better."
[ Laughter ]
"This could have been
a little less cramped."
-Of what, just the two
or if you have three?
-I think if we have three.
But I think if we had three,
we'd be happy.
-I'm very psychic.
I see that you're gonna
eventually have 11.
-You think 11?
-Yeah, I don't know why.
I think you're gonna have
11 children.
-Well, you're very good at this,
so I take your word for it
You have something very exciting
coming up in a couple months
-I do?
-Yeah.
You're doing something
a little out of your --
Well, not out of
your comfort zone,
because I think you're
comfortable everywhere, but --
-I know what
you're talking about.
Hey, you know what I'm gonna do?
That's right.
I'm dying to talk
to you about this.
I'm going to sub -- to hos
one of these talk shows
for Mr. James Corden.
-You're gonna be a fill-in host.
-I'm going to be a fill-in
for one night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They said it was okay to say it.
December 12th, I'll be doing it.
So I'm pract-- I'm learnin
all about it.
-It's very exciting.
You will be great at it.
You'll be a natural.
-I don't know.
-But I do want to point ou
that James,
wonderful guy that he is,
we're on against each other.
So you will be on December 12th,
it's gonna be mano a mano.
-Well, well --
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Look, I'm not trying to put you
in your head.
I think it'll be wonderful
-What can you say?
But I wanted to ask you
a million questions
on and off the air.
you know, I'm already --
I shadowed him last week.
I spent the whole day
doing what I guess you do,
which is from 10:00 a.m.
in the morning,
get together with the writer
and da-da-da.
-Yeah, you're gonna love it.
-I love it already.
-Well, this seems
like a really good segue,
but it is also
a very natural one.
This is a lot like the show that
you're doing on Disney+,
which is you basically --
you explore new experience
and topics
that are interesting to you.
-I'm a little bit --
I'm quite curious.
I'm so lucky to be
on this show.
I'm the host of this show called
"The World According
to Jeff Goldblum."
It's on Disney+ streaming
once a week.
We did 12 of them.
They're half-hours.
And, yes, they're items
of familiarity.
-You did an episode on denim
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Genuinely, but it was
fascinating because I thin
we all, obviously, we have denim
in our lives
and we don't think
much about it.
-These are familiar things
although people love them.
A lot of people love them.
Did you know -- I didn't kno
this -- that half the population
of the world on any given da
is wearing denim?
-Are they really?
-Half, half.
Isn't that something?
-That's great.
-Hey, we found in the deni
episode, I visited --
Where did I go?
To the Levi's store --
headquarters in San Francisco,
where they create
all these things.
You know, denim
in the last couple of decade
with the proliferation
of so much denim,
we're doing horrible things to
the waterways with the dye
and the chemicals,
but they're fixing it.
There are people who are kind of
doing good things in this world.
In this fraught world,
there are people
who are making
their lives better
and the lives of others better
-You did something very cool
There was an episode about
pools?
Am I accurate?
-Pools, yes, yes.
I went to Raging Waters.
I'd never been to there.
We went into
a sensory deprivation tank
And then I went to NASA,
a neutral buoyancy lab.
-How was that?
-It was great.
I talked to astronauts.
It was really good.
You know, I talked to --
I talked to --
You know who was there?
There was a wife
of one of the astronauts
who is currently up
in the space station.
-Oh, wow.
-And she said,
"Hey, you know, he likes you
I'm gonna give him a call.
She got in touch with him.
He called me on my cellphone
I talked to a guy who's up there
right now.
He's still up there.
-Wow.
-He's up there for
four or five months.
-He called you
on your cellphone?
-Yes.
-Was it weeks later
or was it call him now?
-It was there.
-Wow!
-Yes.
And was clear as a bell,
much clearer
than when you're going up
Laurel Canyon, for instance.
I don't know how they do it.
But it was great. It was great
But I'd seen that movie
"First Man" recently.
Anyway, she told me a story that
the last time -- the first tim
that he went up the thing,
as the kids --
they have a couple of boys -
were watching, it exploded
-Really?
-There's a way for them to get
out on a kind of a lifeboa
kind of thing, but they didn't
know for a while.
It was very touch and go
and very scary.
So this last time,
he went up again,
she was telling this story
and I was crying.
It was very, very moving.
Amazing.
-Yeah, that's fantastic.
What a cool show you get to go
and meet people like this
and have those experiences
-Totally cool.
But just like you,
it's kind of like this job
I'm interested in people,
and so are you.
-I am like an astronaut,
it's true.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's not what you're --
-You're an interested person
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Speaking of which, your Netflix
special, I must say,
you must - any woman or chil
within the sound of my voice -
[ Cheers and applause ]
So charismatic
and what a master crafts person.
-Very, very kind of you to say
-It's a beautiful item.